c'est quand même dommage on est là je
connais pas situation récente tu connais
la mienne
un petit peu bête on est mais on va
parler c'était malheureux chacun de côté
alors qu'on allait tous les deux les
organes qu'il faut pour se donner du
plaisir non pas pourtant je le pape
on peut tout une collègue
oui enfin on est des collègues mais
aussi de me faire un nom mais des dons
c'est fou quand même
j'y crois pas un n'a pas de morale
talaga la magnum était coincée du cul tu
vois dans un autre monde dans tout ça à
toi et moi on aurait pu la trame frères
et soeurs t'as pas vu mon slip
c'est
bonne nouvelle vous n'êtes plus
demandeur d'emploi n'arrive pas mac tu
as lisez pas au téléphone votre cerveau
ne fonctionne pas à vous toi vous toi
toi hu a dit toi j'ai pas dis toi j'ai
dis toi mais je vous demande de dire 3 3
comme de plus en plus et c'est ce que je
dis toi j'admets que sur le dos vous
seriez plus à l'esm est bon 3 c3
c'est pas toi vous n'aimez pas les noix
au contraire j'adore tout ce qu'il faut
ici c'est que raciste raciste connard
comment vous allez faire pour vous en
sortir
en fait l'une des terreurs trouver
quelque chose plutôt à val louron peut
pas vous n'êtes pas grave c'est rien
c'est quoi votre petit nid j'adore ce
prénom martin à la montagne martine à la
plage aussi partenaire la ferme tout à
fait je vais leur empire moi même mon
petit dossier de tout le monde croit
martin qui l'a fait c'est quoi le petit
mot de passe par steam et minette comme
mayotte c'est joli ça vous avez une
petite chatte martin